thank you for making a great movie
and like i said on twitter uh you guys
are fantastic together
and i need you to make more movies uh
with the two of you working together
thank you so much for saying that i'm
never working with dwayne again but
no it's not i'm going to find something
we want to find something
something different from jungle right
exactly
yeah we're going to find something we'll
find something we're going to find
something this brings me to a question i
was going to ask at the end and i'm
going to ask it now
uh emily a lot of people have wondered
when you're going to take on a superhero
role marvel dc
uh dwayne have you thought about trying
to convince her to be in some sort of
thing with black adam
yeah yes we've talked about it and she's
gonna play
uh she's gonna play a spin-off called
white betty
it's gonna be amazing it's going to be
amazing you and collider and everybody's
going to love it no look we i've shared
i've sent emily a lot of photos from
black adam and of course she has a great
relationship with jama collette who
is our director of jungle cruise who
just did black atom force 2 and
you know i've always been very very
impressed with the choices that emily
has made now that i've gotten to know
her and become one of her best friends i
now i look back and see that the
probably
just as important are the things that
she's passed on uh
which is really what made her in this
position that she's in today so
would you be interested in playing if
the script no well beside you well
you're going to play white benny that's
happening yeah
but the script was right and then
something was interesting
yeah for sure it's always it's always
about um story
yeah a story and a character i haven't
done so
um it's not something i felt the
inclination to do before but it's not
something i turn my nose off at
all it's just that it hasn't been the
right moment or the right thing
right but white betty you guys yeah
shout out
i'm gonna blow everybody's mind you
passed on a few
he knows he knows oh no no i i
listen if you if you can land her for a
superhero movie
uh you have won the lottery because she
has
absolutely been offered other things